thank you for the introduction
Sam I'm excited to be here this is like
I feel like I'm wrapped in a in a warm
blanket of musical history this is just
fantastic
so my name is David blade oh I am the
co-founder and CEO of a company called
bloom that and basically bloom that is
the best way to send flowers it's pretty
simple we make it incredibly easy to
make you look incredibly good
so we basically approach this by saying
like let's improve the customer
experience let's deliver an awesome
product and let's build a brand that
makes flowers relevant and fun and
engaging and being thoughtful is like
something you can think about 365 days a
year
the topic of today's presentation is
doing more with less and scaling with
simplicity if there's one thing that I
want you all to sort of take away from
today's conversation it's sort of like
just this one thing and that is that you
are the guardians of simplicity within
your organization and it is a whole hell
of a lot easier to add complexities in
than it is to take them out so you have
to be incredibly vigilant to say like no
complexities into this flow and so I
just want you to take away that one
thing from this talk so I'm a simple guy
bloom that started as a simple concept
with a simple question if sending
flowers was as simple as sending a text
message would you send more often and so
we sort of started a company with this
question and our customers answered and
the answer was resoundingly yes so we
basically started bloom that as a bigger
broader gifting idea and narrowed it
down to flowers because we identify that
there was this massive gap in the
experience of sending flowers and I'm
sure that a lot of you in the audience
can relate to this you've used 1-800
flowers you've used FTD
you know that feeling when you're like
oh I've got an obligation coming up
I gotta use something to send something
thoughtful you don't know what if what
you're sending is gonna look like the
picture and just generally it's a
piss-poor experience so we said let's
solve this we can do better than this so
basically the story of bloom that goes
like this I moved to San Francisco maybe
four years ago or so I bought a bunch of
tulips from Whole Foods I threw up a
Shopify website and I bought a hundred
dollars in facebook ads around
Valentine's Day and decided you know
bloom that should be a thing let's start
this off of my patio we were able to
turn that traction into enough to get
accepted into Y Combinator we're able to
turn that traction into enough to read
to raise a seed seed round we're
parlayed that into raising a Series A
and now we're delivering nationwide and
so you sue this or the the progress
there is from back patio to nationwide
in three years so not too bad so things
are going very well today as Sam said
I've mentioned we're delivering
nationwide we do same-day delivery in
the Bay Area and Manhattan a couple fun
facts up here we're attacking an eight
billion dollar industry and we're
growing it because there are tons of use
cases to be thoughtful it's just that
the services provided as sort of the
vehicle for that thoughtfulness are
pretty shitty our team is about forty
five people and then you'll see up here
there's there's an icon there that says
53 proposals there are two things I want
to talk to you about with that is that
one people trust you enough to say will
you marry me with your service you know
you're doing something right and then
second I'm actually not even supposed to
be here today my co-founder Matt
accepted the speaking gig and then he
forgot that he's getting married
tomorrow so that you know you're stuck
with me so you know let's deal with it
and move on so you know things were
going really well today but that wasn't
always the case in fact if we were wined
even nine months ago we were staring
into the abyss
so two years two plus years into you
know founding a company you're standing
in my shoes you started very simple and
you wind up fast-forward you're burning
over a half a million dollars a month
you've got four months of cash sort of
left in the bank what do you do how did
we get here and sort of the the topic of
the top line of this slide is sort of
self-explanatory but expansion is really
hard you know we started simple 90
minute delivery with in San Francisco
7x7
then we expanded 90 minute delivery over
to the East Bay and down to the South
Bay then 90 minute delivery in Los
Angeles and not just part of Los Angeles
we did all of Los Angeles and you know
what Los Angeles is like at five o'clock
rush hour it's a tough thing and then we
expanded to Manhattan 90 minute delivery
and before we knew it this simple
concept had morphed its way into this
beast that you know the assumptions that
we had made how this is going to work
and how the you know economics played
out they were the realities were
completely different once we allowed
this thing to sort of snowball into this
massive complex operation and then the
other thing that we we found is that we
were eventually running three companies
you know we're fairly well capitalized
but we were running a delivery company
so we had a delivery app managing a
delivery fleet we were a marketing and
merchandising company and we were a
flower building a manufacturing company
and at that point like you know we're
deluding what are the things that we do
really well I'm probably not gonna beat
FedEx and uber and whoever else's
experts in getting things delivered so
why would I spend you know my precious
seed capital doing something that is not
my core competency so we were sitting
the situation where it's like really
questioning our survival is this a
feasible business can we get this done
we know that we've set out to really
accomplish this objective of like we
want to make sending flowers better but
is this something that we can scale and
can we streamline our operations to make
the gross margin side of things the
contribution side of things
I guess the equivalent to the user
experience side of
things so we had to sort of I guess I
call it a coming to Jesus moment but we
basically looked into the abyss and said
what do we gotta do to turn this into a
business that makes sense again and what
that involved was getting back to the
basics so the board deck after saying
you know hey guess what guys
board of directors we're gonna be out of
business in four months if we don't do
something so don't worry we've got a
plan basically the plan was we got to
fix our gross margins we've got a
streamline our operations we've got to
retain our top-line revenue and we've
got to do this in a really fast
turnaround time so the way that we
approach this first is we sort of
evaluated how can we do this without
disrupting the user experiences that was
sort of paramount in what we set out to
accomplish to begin with and so we
evaluated where were we over optimizing
for speed or things that maybe were not
absolutely necessary from a customer
standpoint in order to fulfill this
promise that we had of an amazing flower
delivery experience so we looked at as
an example of an anecdote Southbay we
were delivering in one-hour windows it
was costing us a fortune to cover that
area and deliver in one-hour windows we
looked at well what if we pushed it to
two hours can we do that what's the
what's the impact in user experience
well making a small change like that
reduced our delivery costs by over 25
percent we also looked at Los Angeles
and said yo we think this is going to be
a phenomenal market but not right now
we don't have the resources to spread
ourselves that thin so we closed that
market and these are things that I would
say that we had to break down in order
to regroup and build back up the other
thing that we had to do is we evaluated
a pricing structure so again I said that
as we expanded geographies we lost track
of our gross margins and sort of by the
end of it clearly we were we were not
making money on any of our deliveries
net so basically we we decided hey guy
know we've been fighting this but we got
to add delivery fee and you know that's
something that we've been fighting the
whole time but it's really important how
you go about it if you're talking to
your customers you know you know you've
got to break some hard news and your
initial instinct is to sort of
the change and hope no one notices but
that is the worst thing you could
possibly do thankfully we didn't do that
so we wrote a letter to our customers
saying hey you know what
our priority is providing you an
exceptional customer experience to be as
transparent as possible we've tried to
avoid including delivery prices or
delivery fees into the price of your
bloom at deliveries but it's not
feasible any longer we're committed to
providing an exceptional experience and
we've got a charge to do to do that so I
think I'm going a little bit long and
I've got a hair-trigger basically wanted
to become default alive and I think
through the steps of what we did we
landed in that place and how well did it
work three months later we landed
ourselves in a position where we took
ourselves from a half a million a month
to fifteen thousand a month in burn and
that is something that I think you'll
see is very relevant to startups in
today's environment the steroid era of
startups is over and I'll tell you that
like you know this is not something I'd
wish upon my worst enemy however there's
a silver lining our team is so much
better as a result of going through
these changes and the filter that has
been sort of ingrained in the DNA of our
company now is gross margins matter and
that's something that I think if
especially if you're delivering things
you're delivering offline and you're a
revenue generating business gross
margins matter even in the beginning so
I'm gonna sort of blaze through the key
learnings here start narrow start
focused do a couple things really well
you can always add verticals beyond that
don't mask things that don't work you
raise venture capital dollars you're
expected to experiment some of those
experiments are going to fail but don't
cover up mechanical problems within your
business face them head-on
talk to your customers we know this is
an iterative process but it's also how
you talk to your customers be human be
transparent they're going to appreciate
it
if we look at the evolving role of a
founder proceed stage to seed stage to a
to be your role is going to evolve if
you're self-aware enough to know when
you are where you are
it's gonna be a lot easier to make those
transitions and I have clear filters
here but I want to skip to the the one
that I'd said in the very beginning you
were the guardians of simplicity within
your organization no one else is going
to CB Dikembe Mutombo up there everyone
uh so that is what you need to do is be
aware that there's a compounding impact
of complexities and especially as you
scale you're gonna find that you look
back and go how did I get here you want
to avoid that you're the Guardians
so what's next for bloom that we're
gonna continue to launch same day cities
next time it's going to be smarter our
goal here is that we are changing
consumer behavior around sending flowers
so we want bloom that to be a verb so
when someone thinks about you know hey
if so and so's birthday tomorrow we want
the response to be oh you should send a
bloom that we want to be synonymous with
thoughtfulness so we're delivering
blooms across the country I think we're
doing it better than it's ever been done
before if you guys need help being
thoughtful we're the company for you
follow us on Instagram we I think have a
world-class Instagram feed
go to bloom Netcom or I download the iOS
app thank you so much for being here
today we're gonna have a fantastic event
thank you and I think what's next is I
think we've got so we land potentially
right so maybe some this is d squared we
haven't it's name is David so it's David
and David don't get confused I'm gonna
pass this over to Sam thank you guys
have a great day